[BEEPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Cloud IoT Core
is a fully-managed service
that allows you to easily
and securely connect, manage,
and ingest data from millions
of globally-dispersed devices.
Cloud IoT Core, in combination
with other services on Google
Cloud IoT Platform,
provides a complete solution
for collecting,
processing, analyzing,
and visualizing IoT
data in real time
to support improved
operational efficiency.
Device telemetry data is
forwarded to a cloud pub/sub
topic, which can then be used
to trigger cloud functions.
You can also perform
streaming analysis
with cloud data flow
or custom analysis
with your own subscribers.
This diagram summarizes
the service components
in the flow of data.
This hands on lab shows
you how to use Google Cloud
Platform console to create a
Cloud IoT Core device registry
and how to register a device.
It also shows you how to run
a sample to connect the device
and publish device
telemetry events.
You're just one lab away
from completing your quest
and getting your badge.
In case you haven't been
following our other videos,
a quest is a series
of related labs
that form a learning
path on Qwiklabs.
Completing this quest
earns you this badge
to recognize your achievement.
Next up on our quest
is Compute Engine--
Qwik Start-- Windows.